[Musik]
vom bäcker gelb 50
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein ganz einfaches brot
rezepte kennt das im prinzip so ähnlich
schon von meinem magischen paket ein tag
den man nicht kneten muss und trotzdem
wird das brot wirklich perfekt das mag
jetzt solltet ihr auf jeden fall mal
ausprobieren
aus dem teig könnt ihr nämlich auch
magische brötchen machen heute machen
wir ein schönes boot mit
sonnenblumenkernen wenn ihr die nicht
mögt oder austauschen will lasst sie weg
oder nimmt zum beispiel kürbiskerne oder
wohnen oder andere zutaten die ihr gerne
habt ich zeige euch mal eben die zutaten
dafür verwende ich einen halben würfel
hefe 350 gramm warmes wasser 500 gramm
mehl einen teelöffel zucker zwei
teelöffel salz 50 gramm dattel sirup 150
gramm sonnenblumenkerne und einen
esslöffel essig und es ist jetzt
wirklich super einfach gebraucht einfach
eine große schüssel mit die hier weil
sie wirklich schön hoch ist da kommt die
hefe rein das wasser wie gesagt schön
lauwarm etwas zucker tritt auflösen
und weil ich es farblich einfach super
schön finde noch etwas bartels ihr könnt
darauf ahornsirup nehmen oder honig ich
finde das macht dann echte brot farbe
richtig toll und jetzt kommen direkt die
restlichen zutaten mit rein
ich habe jetzt hier ein dinkelmehl ihr
könnt aber auch weizenmehl nehmen
roggenmehl geht nicht den roggenmehl
braucht immer etwas sauerteig aber wenn
ihr wollt dass ich mal ein einfaches
trocken brot rezept bucket und schreibt
einfach in die kommentare
und jetzt hier noch der essig der bewegt
dass die hefe eben auch schnell aufgeht
und jetzt einfach nur mit dem kochlöffel
schön durchrühren bis sich der teig
verbunden hat
guckt so klebrig sohn der jetzt auch
aussehen das war es jetzt schon fest ich
gebe jetzt hier zwei drittel also 100
gramm der sonnenblumen kerne direkt noch
mit rein
den rest hebe ich mir auf die schöne
sitzt noch kurz ein dect intakten ab und
lassen bei raumtemperatur einfach
abgedeckt zwei stunden stehen da darf
jetzt wirklich sich verdoppeln oder
verdreifachen und dann wieder weiter
verarbeitet zubereitungszeit zwei
minuten nicht mal weniger
[Musik]
jetzt ist der hilft aufgegangen und ihr
seht auch der ist relativ flüssig das
gehört aber so also völlig normal und
ich mag das brot sie dann im bus
eisernen topf weil es so weh keine
perfekte kruste bekommt und zwar
passiert beim backen folgendes ich lege
jetzt gleich den teig hier hinein und
hier oben habt ihr diese noppen am
deckel und dadurch dass ich den deckel
verschließen verdampft das wasser im
brot also im teig landet hier oben am
deckel und hier trotz dann wieder
gleichmäßig aufs brot herunter und ich
bekomme einfach eine perfekte kruste
ohne dass ich einen abstoß oder den
dampf backofen nutzen muss und deswegen
ich schön verschlossen es geht darin auf
und ihr habt wirklich ein brot wie vom
bäcker wird echt gut und ihr seht es ist
sie vereinfacht ich hätte jetzt hier
noch den gusseisen topfen bisher mit
webtrends büro und lege die hälfte der
zurückgelegten sonnenblumenkerne hinein
denn ich mag es ganz gerne wenn mein
brot an der unterseite auf sammlungen
kennen und jetzt braucht ihr wirklich
relativ viel mehl denn das ist ja
wirklich flüssig den geht jetzt hier
drauf
jetzt auch schön mail an die oberfläche
und jetzt hier von außen nach innen das
brot einmal formen
aber hier nicht so viel mehr denn das
steckt sonst später eben brot drinnen
das will ich auch nicht aber schon rund
formen
jetzt könnte es gerne mit wasser
besprühen oder bestreichen und dann
kommen da noch mal die restlichen kerner
drauf und ab in den backofen der backe
flusses das heißt ich werde jetzt den
ofen anschalten auf 200 grad ober
unterhitze da kommt das brot hinein mit
30 minuten gebacken mit deckel und dann
nehme ich nach 30 minuten den deckel weg
und bugs einfach noch mal 15 minuten
weiter
[Musik]
jetzt ist das brot perfekt okay ich hab
mich noch umgezogen
lasst euch davon nicht beirren
guckt mal ist es nicht ein schönes brot
oder richtig toll wie es sein muss jetzt
nehmt ihr es hier raus vorsicht heißt du
sitzt hier auf dem abkühlen gitter damit
einfach von unten jetzt nicht schwitzt
und das ist es das perfekte brot aus dem
großen topf ihr habt gesehen wirklich
super einfach ich lasse es noch kurz
abkühlen und dann schneide ich sage ich
schneide jetzt das brot an und mein
wunderbares team darf probieren kommen
das podest ok-team ihr dürft com
doch sehr heißt aber wir haben noch was
vor
ok japan etwas außergewöhnliches
passiert bei euch für die mädels die
laufen ja nix jawohl war ich mit der
außen schöne kruste innen schön weich
und ihr seht das brot ist wirklich super
einfach gemacht mega lecker und weil sie
das rezept nach machen wollt auf 6 -
blog de oder in einer kostenlosen app
und macht zu unbedingt nach postete ein
foto und ich schaue mir das dann also
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]